good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show here on sky news and then
there were six all to play for in the
race to be tory leader and the next
prime minister as mps prepare to vote
again today the first ballot saw the
former chancellor rishi sunak emerged
with the most support but no runaway
lead behind him penny mordant she may
not be as well known beyond westminster
but she seems to have momentum behind
her and the support of the tory
grassroots later on today the list of
contenders will be whittled down further
in the next round of voting this morning
joined by supporters of the top three
candidates the work in pension secretary
to raise coffee who's backing liz trust
julian keegan she's backing rishi sunak
and caroline knox who's supporting penny
mordent it's thursday the 14th of july
six contenders remain in the running for
tory leader for the former chancellor
leading the pack after the first round
of voting
but penny mordent is hot on his heels
excuse me and with momentum for her
campaign growing she seems to have the
support of the tory grassroots
mps will vote again later today to
whittle down the list further in the
list in the in the race to become
britain's next prime minister
extreme heat warning i'm here in hackney
in east london where a new report has
warned this is one of the most
vulnerable communities to the impact of
more intense heat waves
more than eight million households will
start to receive the first direct
payments to help ease the impact of the
soaring cost of living this morning
sri lanka in crisis a state of emergency
and a curfew after protesters stormed
the prime minister's office
families fury relatives of the texas
school shooting victims campaign for an
end to gun violence and demand answers
over the slow police response
if the police officers who are armed and
trained do not want to face this person
that had an assault weapon who does
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world the president and the
pandemic joined by donald trump's former
kobe task force leader for the inside
story of the white house response to the
coronavirus pandemic
and
heroic hounds will meet one of the
outstanding doggies awarded for their
life-changing devotion good boy
[Music]
good morning everybody growing momentum
behind penny mordens in the conservative
leadership race the trade minister and
former defence secretary came second in
the first round of voting with a poll
suggesting she's the clear favourite
among tory members former chancellor
rushi sunak came top of the first ballot
and won the backing of jeremy hunt after
he and nadeem zahawi were eliminated
from the competition and foreign
secretary liz truss was left trailing in
third place as she hopes to unite the
right of the party behind her when she
formally launches her campaign this
morning
these are the numbers from that first
round ballot rishi sunak topping the
poll with 88 votes penny morton she was
um second with
67 votes
liz truss got 50 votes kemi badanok
25 he's out as is jeremy hunt who only
polled 18. under the rules that means
six candidates now go through to today's
second round vote but because they got
less than 30 votes in the deems of
harwie and jeremy hunt as i said both
eliminated
with me now working pension secretary to
raise coffee who is backing liz truss in
the leadership competition talk about
that in just a second just want to talk
though about the urgent question
yesterday after prime minister's
questions our ambulance service is on
high alert there was an urgent question
from labour there was no secretary of
state available to answer that are we
running a zombie government at the
moment
well actually within um just tackling
the issue of ambulances first i get that
as a constituent cnp i've been working
on this actually for a decade and seeing
how the different organizations and
strategies about how we're trying to
improve elements for patients it's our
local nhs that runs uh this uh the nhs
east of england but across the country i
know there's been particular pressure
with handoffs uh
from ambulances into hospitals and it's
those sorts of elements where we really
need the ambulance trust to get a grip
working with the hospitals so we can get
ambulances back out on the road for
patients but nevertheless i appreciate
there was an urgent question yesterday
it's actually westminster practice that
normally it isn't the secretary of state
that responds to a urgent questions but
other other ministers
but importantly it's um um here today as
well because i've stayed imposed in
order to make sure that we can get out
the cost of living payment today which
we are doing and over 1.6 million
households will be receiving 326 pounds
in their bank account today to help them
in the cost of living but if there's a
cobra meeting i'm guessing that the
government thinks that there is a big
issue so you would have thought the uh
health secretary could take time out of
his busy schedule to talk to the public
via tv cameras well i i don't know the
arrangement for the department of health
i know i'm responsible for your
acceptance it's a problem a big problem
i don't know because i don't know what
happened yesterday
services are on high alert so well i
understand that and as i've explained as
a constituency mp my own ambulance trust
has been rated inadequate uh i'm pleased
to see that locally they finally
listened to mp feedback and in my i'm
not responsible for the weather in my
own ambulance trust i'm very conscious
of the need to
operate at a slightly lower and we're
doing that by county but i think it's
because of the impact of high weather uh
sorry very hot weather that the risk to
people particularly elderly has gone up
and therefore it's appropriate that we
do take uh substantial action to make
sure that ambulance trusts are on high
alert and prioritize appropriately what
are you doing as a government
well as a government uh i'm just
conscious that i am uh as we've said
we're trying to make sure ambulance
trusts on high alert and prioritizing
but also the am the hospitals to be able
to unload patients uh to take them into
their care as quickly as possible across
purposes
something different to you to what it
means to the ambulance service when
they're on high alert that means that
they're in trouble
well as i've pointed out one of the
challenges that we've been seeing with
waiting times for patients to get an
ambulance has risen significantly that's
my understanding why uh ministers have
been stepping in to try and get that
prioritization but also with the hot
weather we know that's a bigger risk
particularly for elderly so it is about
making sure the nhs whether for the
patients is working optimal
at full up sorry
full rate to make sure that they can try
and help patients but as i say i'm the
secretary of state for work and pensions
i know that my officials have been
working relentlessly since we had the
announcement of the extra support for
over eight million households and i'm
really pleased that those payments are
landing today and i'm anticipating all
the payments that we will be making will
be done by the end of july okay um why
are you supporting supporting liz trust
she's got a lot of work to do hasn't she
liz trust is a credible
cabinet minister with extended service
and a variety of departments
most recently of course being foreign
secretary and i think she's worked
exceptionally well in representing our
country around the world but
particularly on ukraine she's the lady
that finally she was the one that got
nazanin back did the negotiations but
also her work on trade deals shows that
she can do those negotiations around the
world i think that uh clearly she has
going to be saying in a speech later
today some more of her plans but i've
always been impressed by her ever since
i've got into parliament and i think
that she is also known for getting a
grip
focusing on delivery and uh i also
believe that is one of the most critical
things that we will be doing in the next
two years uh up until the next election
okay liz is the one okay so what would
you say to the supporters of um kemi
badanakin
because you are going to need those
votes and more in order for it to get
over the line why should they come to
you rather than stay with those
candidates
well
um
kay i'm very conscious that this
leadership contest is very intensive and
there's a lot of personal emotions that
people go through they put their
allegiance to one candidate or another
and when their candidate doesn't do as
well as perhaps they would like it can
take a little bit of time for that to
absorb the reason why i think uh
supporters of suella and kemi should
come and join liz is because
a lot of their
policies are in the very similar
direction about having a free economy
about making sure that we stand up for
united kingdom be proud of our country
and indeed having that more
focus on aspects of delivery but a
different approach slightly on how we
tackle economic issues including um she
says that she's open to leaving the
european convention of human rights uh
rhys mark who's also supporting her even
he wouldn't go that far what do you
think well in terms of um one
undoubtedly in terms of the echr the
european convention on human rights that
i think it's fair to say most
politicians believe there's been mission
creep i would suggest and it would have
been a surprise to the british public
to hear uh one morning that a european
court had blocked um in effect that the
plane going to rwanda recognizing our
latest immigration policy but i think at
a meeting the other night
all the candidates i'm aware of that
were
there whether that would think was rishi
as it was reported on one of those
blogs called playbook
they all indicated that uh they would
rather get reform and that is liz's
position uh in order to reform the
church and also to do the bill of rights
and others did say uh that uh if
if necessary uh they would be up for uh
for that as well i think that's you
ducking my question so i'm going to come
back to it do you think that we should
leave the european convention of human
rights i think we need to reform uh
where we are that's what we're doing
well we're doing that with a bill of
rights
and should we leave the european
convention well theresa may
said uh what do you think theresa may
said during the eu referendum
uh that she would rather leave the echr
than leave the european union so i think
it indicates this is a broad view across
a lot of not asking theresa may i'm
asking you well i'm not the person
running for leadership i'm here but you
have a view jury smoke's not running for
leadership but he has a view i mean some
would say he's slightly right of attila
that hun but he still wouldn't leave the
european court of human convention what
i am in favor of is about reforming of
the you're not sure why you weren't
supported
uh and because i am uh here to represent
the government in terms of our cost of
living um at the moment you're asking me
questions about the views of a variety
of leadership candidates in my view but
i'm i'm i'm you're entitled to have your
own view okay i've said very clearly
it's important that we get the reform
and avoid the mission creep and that's
what we will be doing through the bill
of rights it's a bit like a next week uh
recognizing the uh different legislation
that we have we're prioritizing northern
ireland protocol and the reason why that
is is because we want to make sure that
we have the appropriate uh powers to
make changes if necessary so governments
will like to act in different ways to
make sure that they have the believers
they need to uh deploy as appropriate uh
in the future in terms of negotiations
with other people i'll just share with
my viewers and we'll move on only russia
and belarus are not members of the or
yeah not members of the european
convention on human rights we'll we'll
park that there and they can make up
their own minds um talk to me about
suggestions of dirty tricks nadine doris
says there are dirty tricks and rishi
sunak the former chancellor is lending
votes left right and center to keep your
candidate out my main focus is on
getting liz trust into the final two of
the mps that's my choice yeah and that's
what i will continue to do i'm not going
to get into other campaigns okay but
so nadine doris misspoke uh i i don't
know i'm not saying nadine misspoke at
all all i'm saying is i'm focused on liz
truss and that's what matters to me
getting her in the final two okay uh
what do you think about rashid not being
a socialist
in terms of i'm conscious that other
people will come to their own
conclusions
i've been working with rishi clearly
there are some slightly different uh
views on what we should have done on
where various levies and similar
but with collective agreement and
government
of course people will
have been voting for that in the past
but nevertheless this is now leadership
contest and liz will be setting out her
views in her speech lately okay how
surprised are you that penny borden's
doing as well as she is
i think we've got a great range of
talent in our conservative party and in
our conservative government and you know
i know that penny is an assiduous person
but i am supporting this trust because i
think liz has the full package in terms
of experience
grippiness in terms of delivery and
that's why i'll be supporting her um
it's fascinating that she um is
apparently more brexiteering than nadine
doris and
uh jacob reese mark together they made
that comment didn't they when they were
outside number 10 downing street the
other day and i'm sure she voted remain
well i think um uh i think she did vote
remain however so the point is that
we're democrats
and in terms of wants a decision to be
made by the british people
that's respected
and i think you have to judge people
by how they have responded since
the referendum
liz certainly has been out there
selling the uk around the world for both
exports and inward investment she really
has been delivering
on making the benefits of brexit come to
life more perhaps than any other cabinet
minister that i've seen yeah but she was
on her way to indonesia to do that as
well wasn't she but she soon got back on
the plane as soon as she heard that
boris johnson had resigned how long do
you think she's been
quietly planning to be prime minister
um i know uh that
liz has been absolutely focused on her
job and has been in terms of supporting
the prime minister because it was
important to continue disability
government it was right that liz went to
bali to the g20 she didn't turn any
plane around she went there to do what
she needed to do including making sure
that she signed the agreement so that
sweden and finland could have the
fast-track scheme to join nato net this
mechanism has never been deployed before
that's how
important making sure that the interests
of the united kingdom in a global
britain
had already been done before she went to
indonesia
this was important part of her trip in
g20 was to make sure that those
agreements were absolutely signed so
this is why liz will always put country
first
rather than that rather than politics
and the best interests of our nation and
i'm pleased that she did that i know
there'll be other people thinking why
didn't she just turn the plane around
she and come back she didn't she did
what was necessary in order to be the
excellent foreign secretary she's been
and that shows the kind of leadership
that she will i believe lead our country
into just before i let you go um she's
been described as 21st century
margaret thatcher now that is very
appealing to the grassroots of the
conservative party perhaps less so to
the wider public and she will have to
face an election within two years or two
years at the very farthest distance um
how appealing will that be to the wider
public
liz trust is my friend liz trust is liz
truss she doesn't need to be a copycat
of anybody else she is her own person
you know a lady that went to school in
paisley in scotland
then then onto a comprehensive in leeds
and she's a lady who has really
shown that with hard work real focus and
her experiences in schools is why she's
so passionate about improving education
standards and wants to make sure that
the four corners of the united kingdom
stay as the united kingdom but also that
we all lift in terms of prosperity so
i'm absolutely committed and i'm
actually convinced that she will
continue to be able to deliver the
mission of levelling up while also
making sure that we get a grip of all
the issues that we're facing right now
and lead us into victory in the next
generation it's not helpful to compare
it and margaret thatcher then i would
say that she is liz trusts other people
can make their judgments but i think
she's a fantastic lady and i think she
should be the next prime minister we'll
see very soon won't we it's great to
talk to you thanks so much for joining
us thank you
voting in the second ballot in the
conservative party leadership contest
takes place between 11 30 and this
morning and 1 30 this afternoon the
results will be announced at 3 p.m we'll
bring it to you live here on sky news
and we have a special program as well
coming up next week sky news will boost
uh host i should say a live television
debate with those who want to be the
next leader of the conservative party
and the country's next prime minister
the event will take place on monday as i
said 18th of july taking questions from
a virtual studio audience as well you
can be part of the audience for the
debate get involved and put your
questions to the candidates email news
debates at sky dot uk
looking at the morning's papers for you
know here we go full steam ahead for
team mordens as the telegraph splashes
with growing momentum behind the
candidate most popular with the tory
membership the eye describes her
performance as a surge which will rattle
her rivals
in the time is no better word than
search to describe as morden's growing
popularity with tory members
meanwhile the mail calls on the right to
unify behind liz trust to prevent a
sunac premiership
and the mirror reminds the candidates of
the ongoing cost of living crisis as
they continue to pledge tax cuts for the
rich
still to come on the programme for you
speaking to the minister for care and
mental health julian keegan who is
backing rishi sunak in the contest for
tory leader
ronavara's case is on the rise again
we'll speak to the
who's special envoy for coving 19 dr
david nabarro about autumn boosters for
the over 50's
and just after eight joined by the
shadow commons leader thangham debonair
new research has revealed the
communities that will be hardest hit by
britain's worsening heat waves according
to analysis from manchester university
and campaigners friends of the earth
birmingham has the most hard-hit
communities let's get more information
now should we matthew standing by for us
matthew thompson he's in hackney one of
the london communities said to be most
at risk
new to the show very welcome matthew and
bring us up today
pleasure to be here with you okay well
look by all accounts the first heat wave
is over but there's a second one just
around the corner which could hit record
temperatures next week now that might
sound like good news but there's an
uglier side to more extreme temperatures
and that's why a new report out today by
friends of the earth in conjunction with
the university of manchester is warning
that millions more people right here in
the uk could be put at risk for more
extreme summer temperatures if our
climate change goals aren't met we're
here we're here in hackney which is one
of the areas identified by the report as
being most at risk now that's because it
has a high density urban environment
it's got fewer green spaces it's got a
higher number of elderly residents it's
got lots of high-rise buildings which
are harder to cool now in fact hackney
is identified as the borough as with the
fourth largest number of at-risk
neighborhoods in the entirety of the uk
behind only birmingham newham and tower
hamlet
and the point of this report is to warn
that even if we stick to our stated
global climate change goals of limiting
temperature rises to 1.5 degrees above
the pre-industrial average then 6
million more people right here in the uk
will still be exposed to what's called
in the report very hot weather that's
defined as five or more days in a row of
temperatures at 27.5 degrees or more
in places like this temperatures like
that cake could kill and clearly the
higher we go above 1.5 degrees the more
people will be exposed to more dangerous
temperatures so what do we do about it
well obviously more action on global
climate change but then also things like
creating more urban green spaces uh
adapting houses that could be as simple
as installing shutters or the admittedly
more expensive option of installing air
conditioning but the harsh reality is
that even if we do all that okay more
people right here in the uk will be put
at risk for more extreme summer
temperatures okay thanks very much for
the update thanks a lot
firefighters in portugal battling
wildfires during an extreme heat wave
that authorities have linked to climate
change
multiple fires have caused the
evacuation of more than 600 people
around 120 needing medical assistance
with two people a civilian and a
firefighter suffering serious injury
water dumping planes have been helping
the firefighters combat the worst of the
fires in the nation's central area
sri lanka's prime minister has told the
military to do whatever is necessary to
restore order after protesters stormed
his office he declared a state of
emergency yesterday meantime the
president who fled to the maldives on
tuesday is yet to officially submit his
resignation shall we get more on that uh
nicole covering events for us throughout
still in colombo for us this morning hi
nicole looks a lot calmer there today
yes and it could be about to get even
calmer we've just heard from the student
protests
leaders and they have said that they
planned to hand back three out of four
of the government buildings that they
have been occupying now another one is
still under negotiation so this is a
huge development here
they went into the presidential palace
on saturday with those incredible
pictures of tens of thousands of people
streaming in playing on the grounds
inside the gym swimming in the pool well
it seems that today they're going to
leave that building and that means one
of the main tourist attractions for
people here in colombo will be handed
back on wednesday we saw the prime
minister's office also taken over on
this show again thousands of
protesters on the streets they managed
to breach the wall to get into that
building
now the
the leaders of the protest movement say
that they don't want any damage done to
the buildings and they have been trying
to act effectively as guardians you know
to safeguard them so that's one reason
that they're pulling out they also feel
that political progress is being made
and that they are winning against the
rajapaksas it seems that the speaker is
trying to form an all-party government
even though the president gotta buy a
rajapaksa still hasn't officially
resigned he's out of the country but he
hasn't resigned i'm still waiting for a
letter to be delivered to the speaker
even though he has appointed the prime
minister as an acting president so still
a very confusing political situation uh
limbo really here in sri lanka but in
the next few hours we could start to see
those government buildings handed over
okay for now nicole thank you
also making news for you this morning
from today the first of the government's
cost of living payouts for those on the
lowest incomes will begin reaching
around 8 million households the first
payment worth 326 pounds will be sent to
those eligible by the end of this month
with a second installment due in the
autumn
the actor kevin spacey is due to appear
in court in central london later on
today to formally enter pleas to the
accusations of sex offences he faces
five charges involving four of sexual
assault dating back between 2005 and
2013 mr spacey has said he is
strenuously denying the allegations
families of some of the children killed
in the texas school shooting in may have
been lobbying america's politicians to
toughen up gun laws they were in
washington as video from inside the
uvalde school was released showing the
gunman and the slow police response 19
children two teachers died
we had police officers tasked with
protecting our children that day and
they failed because they were afraid to
go in because this man had an assault
weapon
if the police officers who are armed and
trained do not want to face this person
that had an assault weapon who does
an unnamed premier league footballer
will not be suspended by his club
despite being arrested on suspicion of
rape the player was held in north london
earlier this month accused of attacking
a woman in her 20s in june but he denies
the allegations his club feel he can
continue his professional commitments
while on bail
amber heard has failed to get a new
trial after accusations of improper
juror service in her original defamation
case with johnny depp were rejected the
hollywood actor won his case against his
ex-wife after she wrote an article about
being a domestic abuse victim
president joe biden opened his first
visit to the middle east since taking
office by telling israeli leaders of his
determination to stop iran's growing
nuclear programme the u.s and israel are
expected to announce a joint declaration
today renewing calls to take military
action to halt iran's nuclear programme
well yesterday we brought you a starry
starry night courtesy of nasa james webb
telescope and this morning
another starry starry night well not
quite but this is vincent van gogh's
head of a peasant woman painted in
1885 it's revealed a previously unknown
treasure what's believed to be a first
for a uk institution an x-ray taken of
the painting uncovered a self-portrait
of the artist glued
to the back there you go van gogh was
known for reusing canvas to save money
by flipping it round to use the opposite
side
amazing if you haven't seen the
interactive van gogh exhibition you
really should it's amazing
pretty hot again today i think
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well a little bit cooler today but very
very hot again in the coming days the
met office has issued an amber warning
for extra heat covering much of england
and eastern wales sunday monday and
tuesday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now after three weeks on the run dodging
airport staff and animal experts rowdy
the runaway cat has finally been found
the feline escaped from a pet carrier at
boston's logan international airport
there you go finally found and i believe
that he is feline fine
i know try the veal rowdy who was on a
plane with his owners from germany
heading back to the us after 15 years
living away when their left hands the
flight landed the cat ran from her cage
to try to catch a bird that's what they
do after an airport adventure and many
treats still already back calm has
finally been restored beautiful cat that
she is
fierce but fluffy this snow leopard has
been photographed in india and it's in
the telegraph this morning
gorgeous gorgeous thing uh sadly it's
one of just 10 000 left on the planet
wow
get a load of this in the mail a last
cry in battle before death perhaps this
entire skeleton of a soldier of waterloo
has been uncovered in south brussels it
is
200 years old i'm not sure about a death
cry that's as though he's doing the
macarena
uh and a lovely aerial shot here of the
tour de france it's in the guardian
and it is from the lancet
um no it's not it's from the last set
which is very different when you've not
got the n in it to mon vernier there you
go amazing
and how cute is this in the mirror this
morning and alpaca becomes part of the
family in scotland not sure
that the pooch
is particularly happy with it but the
alpaca is very very happy indeed all i
know about alpacas is if they put their
ears back they're about to spit at you
so you better duck
top stories for you on the programme
this morning very welcome to join us on
the breakfast show six candidates still
in the running to become the next prime
minister as the tory mps prepare for a
second round of voting in just a few
hours time
new research reveals the communities
that will be hardest hit by britain's
worsening heat waves
and sri lanka's prime minister tells the
military to do whatever is necessary to
restore order after protesters storm his
office
well a short while ago i spoke to work
in pension secretary to raise coffee
who's backing liz trust i asked her what
she'd say to supporters of suella
bravaman and kemi badanok who were
widely seen to be vying for the same
votes as liz trust to unite behind her
campaign
okay i'm very conscious that this
leadership contest is very intensive and
there's a lot of personal emotions that
people go through they put their
allegiance to one candidate or another
and when their candidate doesn't do as
well as perhaps they would like it can
take a little bit of time for that to
absorb the reason why i think uh
supporters of suella and kemi should
come and join liz is because
a lot of their
policies are in the very similar
direction about having a free economy
about making sure that we stand up for
the united kingdom be proud of our
country
and indeed having that more
focus on aspects of delivery but a
different approach slightly on how we
tackle economic issues
well now um from someone who's
supporting rishi sunak a friend of the
program minister for care and mental
health julian keegan hi it's great to
see you thanks for joining us we've
missed your smiling face i wonder how
much um she's seen next smiling this
morning didn't do as well as he expected
a quarter of the parliamentary party
when you've got eight candidates
that's pretty good i think that my math
says that's pretty good okay but penny
morton's um probably cock-a-hoop this
morning i'm sure penny is really pleased
with her result yeah why do you think
she's done so well
um
i don't know actually i don't know penny
so well um i don't really know penny so
well but you know i still think it's
very clear that rishi has a very strong
following he's got a lot of support he's
got a lot of support of lots of
different people actually north south
brexiteers remainers
lots of different seats he's even got
the support of most of the former
chancellors so there's a lot of support
for rishi where do the next votes come
from though because it looks as though
the other candidates are more to the
right so once they fall in behind
potentially i don't know liz truss um or
then it's becoming much more complicated
for you it's complicated anyway because
if you even look at the mix of people
you know people people are not forming
into the same camps that you could have
seen you know maybe in last elections
there's definitely people who've got
very different views um you know
certainly on brexit but also on other
issues who are actually joining together
and i think that's because i mean
certainly in the case of rishi i think
what we all recognize is
the experience he has and the experience
we need these are serious times where in
serious times need serious people and i
think that's probably why he's building
quite a wide coalition you say that but
um there's been some disastrous polling
for him from uh yougov polar party
members um and it looks as well
definitely as far as they were concerned
with their party member polling more
than 67 soon at 28
so our our party members are pretty
open-minded and they're going to go
through a process where there's five
hustings all over the country and they
will be put through the mill through the
test that actually is the process that
counts it's the only process that counts
and you know there isn't
a single issue like there was last time
they will really put them through and
they'll get to know them better it's a
single issue isn't there it's the cost
of living well the single issue is who
can navigate us through the cost of
living and grow our economy absolutely
who can tackle inflation tackle the cost
of living grow our economy and then cut
taxes is is is the is the approach that
uh rishi is taking yeah but they know
all of that i mean they're not stupid
you're members are they and 67 percent
of them think penny morton well it's a
poll okay there's many many polls as you
know and and actually a lot of the polls
at this point you know you you you can
take a little with a pinch of salt when
they get to know the candidates when
they they don't know all the candidates
very well i mean we don't know who the
final two will be but some of them you
know are not as well known um when they
go through those hustins five times all
over the country the members will then
make make a decision they know they're
making a serious decision they know
they're making a decision about who will
lead the country and actually one of the
most influential countries in the world
during very challenging times um both at
home and abroad with global inflation
and with the euro war in ukraine they
know the size and the magnitude of this
decision oh rishi soon as says he'll run
the economy like margaret thatcher
that's not even close though is it
what do you mean well i mean that uh in
march richie sunak said he would raise
the uk's tax burden to um to its highest
level in 70 years um maggie thatcher was
never you you make sure you make your
decisions based on the times that you're
in i think that's why all the former
chancellors have said we back russia's
plan rishi's plan and we think margaret
thatcherwood as well because obviously
she didn't have to deal with a pandemic
obviously we didn't have exactly the
same situation in terms of a war in
ukraine obviously there was the falcons
wall but that was a long further away so
every your times are your times you get
the hand that you're dealt with can't
say that you're going to run the economy
like margaret thatcher then can you i
mean sensibly is what you mean sensibly
so
what are you saying don't you
corporation tax from 52 to 34 income tax
from i've got the figures in front of me
33 to 25 percent wishing out plans to
raise corporation tax from 19 to 25
percent and no immediate impact on time
what were the numbers that you mentioned
for margaret thatcher from 52 to
52 to 34. yeah and today it's 19.
yeah
it's a totally different situation it's
not just whether it goes won't put them
up there doesn't it yes yes that well
that's that's the current plan so that's
going the opposite direction yeah but
it's not about where the arrow points
it's actually the it is it's actually
the rate and how it compares to other
countries as well and that's that's
that's quite an important point because
what you're doing with your corporation
tax is trying to attract inward business
investment which we are still a very
popular destination for for foreign
direct investment and for business
investment and he's been very innovative
about some of the business investment
focuses he's got with the super deductor
with free ports et cetera it's a very
you know you do what your time it
requires okay um and and i think i think
he is very determined to cut taxes we're
all determined to cut taxes we're
conservatives but you've got to do it
after you've tackled inflation you're
saying
you've brought it under control yeah i
actually mean um with inflation is going
down and not after as soon as it starts
to fall
well that will be a decision for him but
yes when you get to the point where you
think you've got inflation under control
if you do it the other way around you
risk your manifesto you have to know so
you risk if you do when you're saying
brought under control is it as soon as
it starts to fall is it when you feel
that it's plateaued when is it
i think there'll be a number of views in
terms of the economist views but it's
when we feel confident that tattling
that the inflation these inflation
revisers are caused by shortage of
supply posts a pandemic and the whole
supply chain is being disrupted plus the
war in ukraine you know if the war in
ukraine ended in three months time it
would change the picture if if if it
doesn't and it goes on and you know
we've also got the questions of what
happens with grey and et cetera so
there's a lot of very complex things so
it's
we will cut taxes as soon as we possibly
can based on what you said is when
inflation is under as soon as we
possibly can once inflation's under
control if you there's no point in in in
raise if you really don't know when
that's if you raise taxes which then
it fuel inflation which then also raise
interest rates you may have more money
in your pocket but you've got to spend a
lot more there's no point it doesn't
that's when you get into the well
she plans to borrow in order to pay for
tax cuts um and she says that that will
spare extra growth well our borrowing
costs right now are about 83 billion
pounds a year that is you know more than
we spend way more than we spend on
defense even during these times so if
you want to
increase that by more then you know
that's i think that's dead money so i
don't personally um you know i want to
see that come down as much as possible
but we can't you know we can't ignore
the fact we've been through a pandemic
okay the fellow scheme and all the other
schemes were cost a lot of money but
they did protect people's jobs and they
did protect the businesses in our
country why didn't you resign
um well because i'm the social care and
mental health minister and you know the
the so important to everything that i'm
doing the massive reforms we know that
we have to build our mental health
services to get the capacity we know we
have to reform social care to take that
pressure off the nhs and also make sure
we've got much better social care so you
didn't understand because your job's
important
yes and i knew what i had to do kate i
knew all the things i had to do the
first meeting on thursday was with the
new ics chairs i knew what happened
because your job's important did richie
not not think that his job was important
no everyone has their own equation and
he you know he he'd obviously been
closer and had these conversations with
uh
the prime minister
given you've got to get some of me no no
not at all some people resigned and
actually my colleagues you have to make
it's a really hard decision if you
resign
you know that that's what one thing and
i know many colleagues are really sad
that they're not able to do the jobs but
they just felt they had to do this to to
to you know to create uh what's it to to
get rid of the last prime minister or
the current prime minister but in my
case the balance um or that i took was
you know you've got to get a balance you
could have some people running the
country as well so yeah but how much
more i mean the most important job in
the country after the prime minister is
the chancellor of the exchequer
especially during a crisis that could
see us heading towards recession yeah
and because he wants the top job he
decided selfishly some might say to to
resign when we were right in the middle
of it and i'm guessing that
grassroots members who will be voting
who the next prime minister is will see
him as a judas i don't think so i think
it depends on your your view of of the
former prime minister or the current
prime minister you know some people will
feel that but some people will feel you
know we had
um the the chris pincher episode was
just the straw that broke the camel's
back you know these we spent all of our
time when there are serious things and
i've been on this show many times
wanting to talk about mental health or
social care and we've talked about you
know parties or um you know other
people's behavior which is it's not what
we need to be talking about we have to
run the country we have to do it well
who do you think are going to be in the
final two i don't know um but i think i
i i i hope rishi is is is in the final
two i mean you know now everyone's going
to be working very hard for votes it can
move around quite quickly i hope he is
in in the final two but we do have a
fantastic range of candidates and i must
say i am really proud when i open that
paper and see them all it is amazing
right that's a really i'm proud of ours
are you speaking to your guy every day
at the moment yes okay will he come on
and do our debate next week i don't know
but i will ask him for you okay yeah
should he
um i don't i don't know anything about
your debate i don't know when it's
happening or next week it's on monday um
i know there's a vote on monday but you
know it gives them the opportunity to
speak directly not just to other
candidates but to also another member
mps but also to the grassroots i am sure
we've got a ver we've got 100 people in
the audience oh right okay i am sure
everybody will want to i mean you know
the the country quite rightly will want
to ask questions as well it's not just
about us and then the conservative
members so there will be i'm sure a lot
of engagement he's very open i think he
has a great style actually he's very um
even my taxi driver was saying that this
morning so is that yes
i can't answer for him i'm not his media
um person but i will tell him that you
would love him to come on fantastic i'll
put a word in for you i'm sure our
viewers will as well you're very kind
thank you julian keegan thanks very much
indeed tomorrow in dining street for us
this morning hi tomorrow good morning
good morning thoughts
morning kay well the race continues to
be unpredictable and although the
assumption among most people in
westminster and indeed all the other
campaigns is that rishi sunak who tops
the poll yesterday will make it into the
final two he's had a serious run for his
money from penny mordant little-known
among the public not in cabinet for
quite a long time but she seems to
really have momentum she was second
placed among mps yesterday ahead of the
foreign secretary liz truss and this
polling from yougov among conservative
party members really electrified the
atmosphere in parliament yesterday
showing that penny mordant is ahead not
just in general but in a head-to-head
contest with every other person in the
race at the moment she would win with
the members now you heard jillian keegan
there saying well this contest has
barely got going there will be a very
long process of the final two going on
hustings around the country and people
will get to know them better and they'll
get a sense of who they both are which
they don't have at the moment and
they'll also see she says that rishi
sunak has been in the treasury he's had
a big job he has the experience and that
will triumph at the end she said members
understand the magnitude of this
decision but certainly
the idea that many people want a fresh
start someone who's not been in a senior
position under boris johnson is starting
to really worry at some of the more
established candidates liz trust
launches today she needs to make up
ground there are other candidates on the
right who may fold like suela bravaman
and kemi badanok and those votes may go
to her but they are showing no signs of
wanting to leave the contest yet and
unless she unites that vote on the right
of the party she may find it difficult
to get to the next stage hello again
welcome back to the breakfast show here
on sky news tomorrow is standing by in
downey street for us this morning we've
been hearing from the campaign teams
again this morning already tomorrow
that's right six still in the race and
there will be five or maybe even fewer
by the end of the day because mps are
voting again from 11 30 to 1 30 and the
lowest-placed candidate we will find out
the results of that about three o'clock
the lowest place candidate goes out
there's no thresholds this time and
anyone else who decides to concede may
go out as well but we're looking at five
candidates maximum by the end of today
and more rounds of voting into next week
with and it's really unpredictable rishi
sunak as expected got the most support
from mps yesterday but not by an
enormous margin he got 88 votes and
penny mordant has stormed into second
place with a feeling that she really
despite being relatively unknown outside
westminster has got the momentum with
her and if liz trust is to try and get
into that final two she will need other
right-wing candidates to fall away and
that support to go to her and what we
saw yesterday kay is you can never
guarantee whose support you're going to
pick up there are no friends in politics
jeremy hunt dropped out of the race
yesterday i think tom tugan had
supporters would rather hoping that he
would give them an endorsement my
colleague mari hears that they're very
angry about that penny mordon who
supported hunt for the leadership in
2019 and lost her cabinet job as a
result might have been hoping for his
endorsement too but he endorsed rishi
sunak in the end so you can't really
guarantee where people are going to go
and it's very difficult to engineer
anything but certainly we're looking at
some of the lesser-known candidates like
kemi badanock suella bravaman staying in
this race for now with little sign that
they are going to want to drop out at
this stage
um
as far as larry's concerned he's not in
the slightest bit interested they do say
if you want a friend in politics get a
dog not even the cat's interested at the
moment as far as we were hearing from
therese coffee weren't we now she is
supporting liz tross
that's right therese copy coffee is a
longtime ally of liz trust and her
message was liz has the whole package
liz truss is launching her campaign
today we haven't heard from her yet she
has been in cabinet pretty much
continuously since 2014 she's very
experienced and her message will be that
this is to quote somebody not in the
tory party no time for a novice that
some of these other candidates do not
have the right experience they've never
worked in the treasury as she did in the
past and so they don't have the
experience to walk straight in she will
say on day one and get things done
she'll also talk a bit about her
background she grew up in leeds went to
a comprehensive school she'll say she
wants to make this an aspiration nation
i think try to draw a dividing line with
rishi sunak who obviously went to a
public school and is very wealthy so
so therese coffee will be hoping that
today if some of the other candidates on
the right drop out of the race she can
start to develop some momentum this is
what therese coffee told us
okay i'm very conscious that this
leadership contest is very intensive and
there's a lot of personal emotions that
people go through they put their
allegiance to one candidate or another
and when their candidate doesn't do as
well as perhaps they would like it can
take a little bit of time for that to
absorb the reason why i think uh
supporters of suella and kemi should
come and join liz is because
a lot of their policies are in the very
similar direction about having a free
economy about making sure that we stand
up for united kingdom be proud of our
country
and indeed having that more
focus on aspects of delivery but a
different approach slightly on how we
tackle economic issues back to you
shortly tomorrow if i may let me bring
in dr david nabarro though we've had
some technical difficulties with us now
we want to talk to you of course um
doctor about what on earth is going on
with covert infections on the rise again
oh look so
his screen has frozen again i'm not sure
whether dr nabarro can hear me
um doesn't appear that he can which is
such a shame because he's such an expert
when it comes
to the global covert 19 response is the
chair of the global health at
imperial college um 300 000 infections a
week is what we're looking at as far as
covid is concerned here in the uk which
country is uh struggling the worst at
the moment
well there's a 23
increase at 1.7 million people estimated
to have the virus at the moment
scotland
has the biggest increase 42 percent
increase 250
700 people infected
68 and a half thousand tested positive
in wales and 59 900 in northern ireland
dr nabarro i don't know we're having
technical issues with you today why are
we seeing such an increase in covered
to be back with you and i'm sorry about
the internet but this virus
just is capable of constantly evolving
and changing
and the reason why we've got an increase
is it's changed yet again
and it's become
too clever for us and it can break past
our immune defenses and that's why the
numbers are going up in addition of
course we're all mingling around and
we've got out of the habit of our
precautions our face masks and the other
things that matter so much so my advice
to everybody is please this virus hasn't
gone away it's not killing so many
people but it's really unpleasant
especially if you get long covered so i
would ask everybody just remember the
precautions that we worked on so hard
two years ago
they still matter and we still got to
put them in place even though we don't
like it we have to go on respecting this
virus
and what about inoculating boosting the
over 50s how does that help if it's
changing all the time this virus well
the one joy is that these vaccines that
were developed with such amazing skill
early on
do seem to prevent us from dying when we
get covered k i had covid about six
weeks ago and i'm in that age group
which really orton to get the virus
because we can suffer very bad
consequences but because i've been
vaccinated although it was a horrible
experience
i did not get seriously ill i did not
die and that's what i want to ask
everybody to do especially if they're
older especially if they've got diabetes
make sure you're vaccinated and make
sure that if you're offered a booster
you get it i've had two basic
vaccinations and two boosters and i
would encourage everybody who can to get
their vaccination status as up to date
as possible it'll stop you from dying in
most cases which is the important thing
we must leave it there i'm afraid really
wanted to talk to you for longer out of
time we'll see you very soon thank you
very much